Johnson: So this presentation
is called GWT Can Do What?!
And I sort of chickened out.
On the session agenda
it says, "GWT Can Do What?!?!"
And I was feeling
really ambitious
a couple of months ago
when we had to submit the title
in Abstract.
But over the last couple days,
you know,
I didn't want to set
expectations too high,
so I removed one
of the question mark-
exclamation point pairs.
So maybe if you lower
your expectations--
if a demo screws up
or something,
it will not be a big deal.
My name is Bruce Johnson.
I run the Google
engineering office in Atlanta.
I'm the engineering manager
of Google Web Toolkit.
And I was the guy
a few years ago
who had the silly idea
that, you know,
hey, what if you actually
just tried to compile Java
into JavaScript?
Well, it turns out that
that does work pretty well.
And since then we've seen the
GWT engineering team grow a lot.
And we've seen the scope
of what GWT does
really, really increase
as adoption of GWT has spiked,
both inside and outside
of Google.
So a lot of you might know that
GWT is an open-source project.
And if you want to get
some idea
of the rate of progress
within GWT,
I dare you to subscribe
to the Subversion
and commit log emails.
And let those go to your inbox
for a couple of days
and see how long
you can take it.
But anyway,
to emphasize the point,
this is all open source
development.
You can watch the code reviews,
design discussions happen
yourself.
Just go to the Google Web
Toolkit contributors group
on Google,
and please join right in.
I would guess that a lot of you
may already do that,
and that's fantastic
that you're here.
So as we start to think about
GWT 2.0,
the thing that is
mainly on my mind is,
oh, my gosh,
this is a lot of stuff.
And there used to be a time
when I could keep it all
in my head.
And I definitely cannot
do that anymore.
So really, the best
I can hope to do is excite you
about what's coming in GWT,
and persuade you to go
to these other talks,
where you will learn about
the real details
from the engineers
who are developing GWT
and really big applications
built with it.
So a quick survey of the talks
to come in the track.
Measure in Milliseconds.
If you know anything
about GWT,
you know that we're sort of
performance fanatics.
This talk by Kelly Norton
will explain why that matters
from the end user's
perspective,
and go through some of the
sort of usability implications
of the technologies we include
in GWT to help you have
higher performance
applications.
Ray Ryan is gonna talk about
Architecture Best Practices.
And using as an example
a from-scratch rewrite
of Google's AdWords
campaign management interface.
The interface that
advertisers use
to control their ad campaigns
on Google.
A fairly important application
for Google.
And Ray was heavily involved
in the architecture of that
in the rewrite in GWT.
Then Lex Spoon and I are doing
a talk about
some compiler details--
especially code splitting--
so that you will understand
how to use code splitting well,
and how to basically read
the tea leaves
of the information that GWT
compiler can provide to you
as you optimize.
The guys from Lombardi,
Alex and Damon,
are coming back to discuss
lessons that they've learned
in building
a really phenomenal
diagramming application
in GWT.
I highly recommend that talk.
Another one
from Ray Cromwell.
Ray had a talk with Extreme
last year
that was an absolute hit.
And I think he's going to
pull that off again.
This is about progressive
enhancement using GWT Query,
which is a JQuery-like library
built with GWT.
And he's gonna do another talk
that promises lots
of cool demos--
that combines a bunch of
different Google APIs together
using GWT in ways that
you might never have imagined.
And then most of
the GWT team,
or maybe half of us
are here,
and we'll be doing
a fireside chat later,
so we can talk shop then.
We're excited about that.
I want to emphasize especially
this GWT Query talk
because Ray has done
such a good job with GWT Query.
And the programming model is
so powerful
that we are going to roll
that functionality
into GWT itself--
into the proper source control
and distribution
and everything.
That may not be in 2.0,
but it will be soon after.
So you definitely want
to come to that talk.
It's sort of underselling
itself, based on the title.
But he's gonna explain
this awesome new library,
and the work he's done
to improve it.
Okay, on to the overview:
what's coming in 2.0?
So first of all, as you saw
if you went to the keynote--
hopefully you did, you heard
about the whole phone thing...
[laughter]
Uh, okay, you did.
You saw Andrew Bowers talk
about something called,
well, in-browser hosted mode--
an improved version
of hosted mode
coming into a 2.0.
If you've seen us talk about
O-O-P-H-M, or "OOPHM"--
because we like pronouncing
awkward-sounding acronyms
on the GWT team...
But we're probably gonna have
to abandon that
by the time
we actually ship it
because nobody really likes
saying OOPHAM.
Some additional compiler
enhancements.
Code splitting, which was
also mentioned in the keynote.
Um, ImageBundle on steroids--
a new technology called
ClientBundle.
Improved layout and panels,
which is always a source
of angst.
Even using GWT today,
we've got some
really promising solutions
in that area.
And then, a grab bag
of not-to-miss features.
So let's get started
with hosted mode.
All right.
So first of all,
hosted mode is good.
I would not use GWT at all.
I would not be interested
in cross-compiling
to JavaScript whatsoever
if it weren't for
hosted mode.
Hosted mode is the key to
productive development in GWT.
And if you aren't using
hosted mode,
you're not really using GWT
the way that we intended
for it to work.
It gives you the ability
to debug in Java.
It gives you the ability to make
a change in your source code
and hit refresh
in the hosted browser
so that the changes
are picked up immediately.
And it is important to mention
that this is not
a simulation of a browser.
It actually is a browser.
We just had to carefully
wire it into the JBM
and bytecode layers
so that it can do
all the magic work.
But you see
the screen shot here.
It isn't your browser,
right?
It's a special SWT window
that we had to construct.
Which brings us to
a problem:
it's actually too special.
We were only able
to really make that happen
for one browser
per operating system.
GWT does allow you
to develop
on MAC and Windows
and Linux.
but on each of those
you can only use hosted mode
for a particular browser
on that development OS.
In other words, you get
Internet Explorer
for hosted mode on Windows.
You get Safari on Mac,
and you get some
ancient version of Mozilla
that we--
[chuckles]
It's embarrassingly old.
It's not at all like 3.5 era.
It's also a particularly
painful thing
because layout--
The existing GWT panels
don't solve layout perfectly.
You still have to know a lot
about CSS.
And CSS is
a very powerful technology.
But as you saw, and everybody,
I think, laughed about
the CSS's awesome mug
in the keynote,
you do spend a lot of time
debugging CSS, like it or not.
And it's really hard
to do that in a hosted browser
because we don't--
It's our own browser chrome,
right?
So we aren't able to allow
extensions like Firebug
and all these great things.
They just aren't available
at the same time
as hosted mode debugging.
So there's this other
kind of related phenomenon,
which is that it's hard
to use browser plugins
that expect to be running
in a certain context.
So Flash and Applets
and even Gears
don't always work well
in the hosted browser.
So it can be hard to debug
interactions with plugins.
So what you find is that
you compile a lot.
And as soon as you start
doing that,
you realize that the compiler
is not the fastest aspect
of the GWT offerings.
It's, some have said, slow.
Just a random search for GWT
on Twitter
the night before last
uncovered this little gem.
That, you know,
"one pain point with GWT,
it takes too long
to compile."
It's not an issue
in hosted mode,
which is good.
But it slows you down
while fixing browser issues.
Since hosted mode
really is a browser,
what he means by
"fixing browser issues" means
fixing CSS and other types
of issues
that can't be accurately
reflected
in the hosted browser today.
But the compiler isn't meant
to be an alternative
to hosted mode.
You're supposed to use
hosted mode
to get your app
like you like it,
then compile it.
So we had to make some
pretty significant changes
to the hosted mode.
The solution, it turns out,
is to create a browser plugin,
and have your Java bytecode
drive the browser plugin.
A native code,
plug it into the browser.
Then create such a plugin
for every browser
that we want to debug against,
and make that work
across the network.
And so I think it's best
just if I show you.
So...
now I'm gonna do a little
cross-window dragging here.
Always difficult
and dangerous.
All right,
so this is Showcase,
which is sort of the--
wow, this is actually
gonna be really hard to--
I can do it.
All right.
Does that look okay?
Okay.
So we're gonna do...
Showcase.
I still have the term OOPHAM
in there.
The first thing you'll see
is...this.
This is the highly
unattractive,
and because it's unfinished,
UI.
And it basically says that
we are running
a hosted mode session
as a server.
So hide that one down here.
Now hosted mode is sitting there
waiting for us.
And I can enter the URL
from--
Oh, yeah,
you can't see this.
Actually, hang on.
I gotta--
This is driving me insane.
So I hope this is not gonna,
like, totally demolish
what we've got going here
with the video,
but we've gotta do it.
Yeah.
How's that?
Okay, now--
Okay, sanity regained.
All right, so now I navigate
from a regular Safari instance
to the Showcase URL.
It's what I would have
normally done
in the hosted browser,
except this is
regular old Safari.
Which means I get
all the tools
that I would expect to have
in Safari...
and any other plugins
that run in Safari and so on.
So now hosted mode is
no longer trapped
inside the hosted mode
browser.
So that's the--
That's not the excitingest part.
This isn't
the excitingest part either,
the next thing
I'm gonna show you.
But it is excitinger.
All right.
So...
we also have this
working in Firefox.
So I'll visit the same URL.
But there's a couple
of interesting things
to point out here.
You're seeing
both instances run
against the same
hosted mode session.
And that works fine.
It's like a server
on top of your Java codebase.
And so if we look back
at the debugger...
here...
we just see a thread here
and a thread here
for each of the browsers
that are connected.
Okay.
Now that's pretty cool.
And then you want to
do things like debug CSS, right?
So this is one of
the key use cases
for out of process hosted mode
for this new plugin-based
hosted mode...
to be able to do things
like use Firebug...
at the same time.
So I'm able to make
real-time changes.
And especially when
you're tweaking CSS,
it really helps
to be able to have
the full power of Firebug,
even while you're debugging
your Javacode at
the same time.
So hopefully this is gonna
go a long way
towards making people able
to use hosted mode
for the trickiest situations.
All right, now...
That also, by the way,
was not the excitingest part.
What to me is
the excitingest part
is the fact that if you're
developing a cross-browser--
You have to remember,
not every browser runs
on ever operating system,
obviously.
Internet Explorer,
not to name names,
doesn't run on Mac,
for example.
So--but it has a large
market share,
so I need to support it,
obviously.
I'd like to be able
to debug with hosted mode
against Internet Explorer.
But I want to run Eclipse
on my Mac, of course.
So that works too.
I have the VMWare session
here.
And it's actually using
cross-process communication
across the network
to hit the server
that is running hosted mode.
And now you can see
all three sessions are running,
and they each have
their own log
at the same time.
[applause]
Cool.
But wait, there's more.
[laughter]
That's what you're supposed
to say during the demos.
You're supposed to say,
"But wait, there's more."
Yeah, we'll do questions
at the end
because there's a microphone.
And for the video's purposes,
we have to have people
do that.
So it just wouldn't be
a hosted mode demo
unless we showed
hitting a break point, right?
So I clicked on the hyperlink
in Internet Explorer,
in a VMware session.
Triggered a break point
back on my Mac in Eclipse here.
And I can step through,
a line at a time.
I can do everything
that I'm used to doing
in hosted mode,
including things like getting
the inner HTML associated
with widgets and so on.
So this is actually going back
to Internet Explorer,
and extracting
the DOM structure
as an HTML
and sending it back
so that we can stay
in our debugger
and not have to constantly
flip back and forth
when we don't want to.
Also, we think,
pretty time-saving.
And then, another thing
that it would not be--
it would not be
a hosted mode demo
without showing
is the ability to...
quickly refresh.
So...okay.
I'm gonna change
this subtitle right here.
"Showcase of Features."
"Edited Line..."
And then,
refreshing the browser.
And you see the edit
took place.
Okay, that is out of
process hosted mode.
Where were we?
Okay, so now we talk a little
more about the compiler.
The best thing to do is
not compile,
if I haven't made that clear,
okay?
Caveats and mumble, mumble.
So this is times
on my MacBook Pro,
which is a two-core computer,
um, compiling
a Showcase sample
in one inversion 1.6 of GWT.
It took 144 seconds.
But we keep adding features
to the compiler--
optimizations, code splitting,
and all that.
That takes time.
So as much as I'd like
to show you
the next bar being smaller,
um, it's actually larger
right now.
There are still some tweaks.
You know, we'll spend
a little time with JProfiler.
And we can probably
get the compiler
a bit faster still.
But the reason
it takes so long is
GWT does an optimized version
of the compiled script
for different browsers
and different locales
and different context.
It's one of
the key strengths
in why GWT does actually
produce
really fast JavaScript code.
So there's sort of
a limit to
how fast the compiler can be
in theory.
It's why we invest so heavily
in hosted mode.
But there are still some things
we can do and have done.
In GWT 1.6, which is available
as a download right now,
there is a dash local workers
flag.
And you can specify the number
of job processes you'd like--
sub-processes
you'd like to start
to run the compiler
to compile those permutations
in Parallel.
So if you find the sweet spot
relative to your amount of RAM,
and relative to your number
of cores,
you can actually
speed things up a lot.
As you see here
with local worker SQL-2,
I can compile 25 permutations
in about two minutes.
That's still not great.
So in 2.0 we're adding
a dash draft compile flag.
What this says is,
"Look, I just really want
to compile fast.
I don't mind if the output
isn't as good."
So that the compiler does
fewer optimizations,
and the resulting script runs
the same,
but isn't as optimized.
And you wouldn't want
to ship it into production.
But it does speed things up,
as you can see.
So now we're about
1/3 of the time as we were
without using these flags.
There's a trick,
we've said from the beginning,
that you should do if you're
doing a bunch of desk compiles,
which is to restrict the number
of permutations
in your GWT module.
People call this
a single-perm compile,
and things like that.
You can--
using an XML element
called setProperty,
you can restrict
certain values.
You could say only compile
for user agent IE6,
for example.
In GWT 1.6,
we added the ability
to set that as a subset--
a multiple value.
So it's not just exactly
one permutation.
You can actually kind of
craft your own number
of permutations.
I could, say, compile
for Safari and IE6
and English and French.
Even if the total number
of permutations
are really large,
you can kind of pick and choose
the subset
that you're actually
focusing on at the time.
And if I do that,
you can see,
you can save a lot of time.
Now we're at about 1/9th.
And did I mention that
hosted mode is a lot faster
than a compiler?
Plus, you can debug.
There's a lot of good things
about hosted mode.
But we also say refresh
rather than restart hosted mode.
So you can leave
the hosted mode browser running.
Occasionally you'll get
an error message
from the JVM that says
something about not able
to hot swap end code.
You can completely
ignore that.
You can say don't talk to me
about this anymore.
Because the hosted mode
infrastructure
automatically recompiles things
into RAM for you.
So it will always work,
and you can safely ignore those.
In other words,
do run hosted mode
for long periods of time,
and do hit refresh,
and you get this kind
of turnaround time.
So basically, instead
of waiting 186 seconds,
you can wait two seconds to see
the results of your change.
And you can still do
all the things
you would have needed
to compile for.
You can now do that using
out of process hosted mode,
the plugin-based
hosted mode.
Just to underscore the point.
[laughter]
Plus, I just discovered
Keynote Animations,
so like, I'm definitely gonna be
over the top with that.
All right, let's talk about
code splitting.
What happens is your scripts
become really big.
Especially
if you haven't done
enough JavaScript development
beforehand
to be incredibly afraid
of browsers.
You might not approach
a GWT project--
hey, I did turn that off.
I swear.
You might not approach
a GWT project
with sufficient trepidation.
You might feel
a little too confident.
You might say, hey, wow,
this is great.
I can write Javacode,
and it just magically turns into
super-optimized JavaScript.
Well, we do optimize,
but it's still proportional
to the amount of Javacode
that you write.
So don't be complacent.
You want to think about
the size of your script
and performance
from the very beginning.
For one reason,
you have to download that script
when the user visits
the site.
So if you get one megabyte
of JavaScript,
that is just going
to take a while.
Especially for users
with slower connections.
It also can trigger
some pathological behavior
in certain browsers,
who shall remain nameless.
The parsers were written
at a time
when nobody expected
to be parsing
a megabyte of JavaScript.
So some of the internal data
structures that they use
have worse than linear time
with respect to the number
of lines of JavaScript code.
There is one thing we can do
and have done in GWT 2.0
which is to break
really long script blocks
into just multiple
script blocks.
Believe it or not, just
inserting extra script tags
does something to reset
the internal compiler--
I mean, the JavaScript
parser state--
so that it actually sort of does
avoid that script time--
uh, the pathological behavior.
So we help you out somewhat,
but still, in general,
the UI is locked up,
and that's not good.
That's the last thing you want
to do is hang the browser.
Remember from the keynote,
"I will not hose the browser
with JavaScript."
We help you write a lot
of JavaScript,
but we still don't want you
to hose the browser.
So...and then also remember
that you--
A lot of times with GWT
you run code
to produce DOM structures
that then render as the UI.
If you have to parse
a lot of script at startup,
that adds latency
to the beginning--
before your code can
start running to build the UI,
that then has to get rendered.
Long story short,
you don't want to wait too long
to parse a really large bit
of JavaScript.
So it seems like a problem
for GWT to solve.
Did I mention I discovered
the animations in Keynote?
So we've got the ability
to drop split points.
The API is called GWT.runAsync.
And all you do is pass
a callback into runAsync.
Okay, so that's an example
of the split point.
If the code fragment
successfully downloads,
the onSuccess callback
will be called...
But it's possible that
the code fragment might fail
to download if there was
a network pickup
or a problem like that.
In which case...
you have that.
I promise there's no more
annoying animations
after that.
I pretty much milked
that joke.
All right, so does that
kind of make sense?
The idea is
the compiler can see
what's within
the onSuccess method there.
And it does something
that Lex deemed dead for now,
code elimination.
And so it starts with that
as the beginning
of a set of dependencies.
So this is sort of a--
it creates a split point
in the dependency graph
that the compiler can analyze,
and to make splitting
decisions.
So let's see what happens
when we split Showcase up.
The original Showcase,
the unsplit version,
requires 108K gzipped,
which is like, I think,
388K on gzipped.
But you should always
sort of script gzipped.
Anyway, 108K.
And then the split version
can actually get
the Showcase UI up
and interactive
with about half
that amount of script
just by carefully dropping
some split points in.
Let's look at the way
we did that in Showcase.
That's what happens
if you just stop the Java side
of hosted mode.
All right...
It's also, I guess,
worth mentioning
that code splitting--
we designed it to not require
any particular
server-side support.
So you can actually even
run split code directly
from the file system,
which is what I'm doing here.
'Cause the last thing you want
is to be forced to use
some complicated servlet
configuration,
and that sort of thing.
So we did not do that.
So if you'll just watch
over here on the screen
to the right,
you can watch as new bits
of code are being fetched.
We've created a split point
everywhere that there's
a primary hyperlink here
in the tree.
So you can see it--
There's really two things.
You can see that the code loads,
which is cool.
But even cooler is the fact
that you can't tell
that the code is loading.
Just watch the UI for
a second.
I mean, it pops in,
essentially, immediately.
Because we've amortized the cost
of loading that code.
You know, we split
what was 108K
across a bunch
of different actions.
And users do expect, sometimes,
there to be a slight delay
when they do something.
If you can make your code
split well,
then the delay will be
negligible.
And so it's good
all around.
Okay, we saw that.
So there's a few things to know
about runAsync.
So it is intentionally
developer-guided.
As these sorts of techniques
are starting to become
popular,
there's different philosophies
about
how code splitting
should work.
We say that it should not be
an automatic process.
We say that the developer
has to know
what sort of functionality
might be appropriate time
to split out some code.
Where there might be
a network delay.
For example, clicking
on the settings page
is a perfect thing.
You rarely click
on settings--
like once out of every ten times
you use an application.
That's a perfect time
to be willing to suffer
a delay.
So you would put the UI
for showing settings page
behind the split point.
Let's think about a system
that didn't work this way.
That just sort of
magically figured out
how to split your code.
You don't know what's
gonna get split out when.
I mean, maybe there's some sort
of magical machine
learning algorithm or something
that could do this for you.
But that may be a ways out.
It's actually intentionally
asynchronous
because it's really
important
not to lock up
the browser UI
while the code
is being fetched.
And importantly,
the user might click
on the settings page,
or some other expensive piece
of functionality,
but then immediately change
his or her mind
and want to go do
something else.
So we can't have a situation
where you call a method
that requires code
to be fetched,
that literally hangs execution
of the JavaScript thread.
Because that thread is
the same thread
that allows you to interact
with the browser.
So it is asynchronous.
It's not the easiest
programming model in the world.
But it does provide
the best user experience,
which is ultimately
what we're after.
It also forces you to think
about failure paths.
Imagine a situation where
there weren't a callback,
and there weren't a method
called "on failure"
that you had to fill in.
You might never think
about it.
If just some random exception
got thrown
in the case of failure,
you would never know where
you should and shouldn't try
to catch this "fragment failed
to load" exception,
and so on.
So either you don't ever
catch it,
in which case you don't have
good error handling.
Or you get paranoid
and wrap every single method
in a try catch.
Because anything could
potentially fail.
And that's bad for the reason
that it would increase code size
and slow things down.
So we tried to be really careful
in how we design it.
And as you get to know the way
that code splitting works,
and use it in your own
applications,
we hope that you'll be mindful
of the reasons
that it was designed
the way that it is.
Also important to note
that the split point
doesn't actually mean
it will delay at that point.
It's not necessarily true
that you will fetch
exactly at the moment
the split point is reached
in the control flow.
We can do things like
pre-fetch.
That would be possible.
You can do that by creating
a custom linker.
It would also--
the fragments
are perfectly cacheable.
They have strong name URLs
so that you can provide
never expires headers
so they can be cached locally
in the browser.
So it doesn't necessarily
mean slow.
It also doesn't necessarily
mean split.
The compiler can choose
to ignore a split point.
It tries to do a good job
of finding a balance
of minimizing the total number
of fragments,
making them cacheable.
Honoring all the different
static dependencies
in your code.
And--which is all that stuff
I just said--
And to understand more
about the specifics here,
I invite you to come to the
"Story of Your Compile/
Reading Tea Leaves" talk that
Lex and I are doing tomorrow.
We'll be going into this
in a lot more detail.
I guess one last point is...
we are really excited
about this feature
because it is so very hard
to do this any other way.
We've seen teams
try to split code manually
across JavaScript files,
and think about
when they should load,
which module, and create
these elaborate diagrams
and so on.
And they might get it working
this week.
But then a month from now,
other people come along,
and they write code
not understanding
the dependency order,
and they call a function that
wouldn't yet have been loaded.
And, you know,
you have an explosion.
Okay, now, ClientBundle.
First let's revisit
ImageBundle,
which is sort of
a new direction
that we went in 1.4
with GWT.
And it leverages the fact
that GWT can do
compile time cogeneration,
and compile time
resource generation.
I'll explain how that works
a little bit.
So let's say the easiest thing
for you to do
in your email application
is to organize your files
as separate, you know,
jpegs or something.
And they're scattered in a way
that makes sense to you
or to your designers.
Okay, that's great.
But that's not the same as
what's good for the end user.
So there is this divide
between
how you're going to organize
your code in development,
and how you'd like it to be
served for high performance.
User experience,
you know, in production.
So when we add up the sizes--
and I actually did this--
add up the sizes
of these individual images,
it comes out as something
like 20K.
But what GWT lets you do is
construct an ImageBundle,
which is a simple,
cogeneration-based API
that can, at compile time,
take those images,
put them together
in a single-image strip,
and provide you hooks so that
you can refer to them
as viewports, basically--
sprites--
within the one image.
So that means
some goodness happens.
Some of the goodness is
you remove
all the redundant image file
header information.
There's just a boiler plate
in every individual image file.
By combining these into one,
you actually can remove
that redundancy.
And so, literally,
the combined image is
actually smaller than
the individual images in total.
In terms of HTTP requests,
it's really huge.
It means one request,
that is, instead of 11.
Which is really important
because some browsers still have
a two-connection limit.
In other words,
if I'm going to fetch
11 different images,
the two outgoing connections
are completely saturated.
So if I've got an RPC
that I need to do,
it's waiting in line
behind 11 images
being requested
at the same time.
So your user is
twiddling their thumbs
and maybe thinking about
going to check out
Twitter or Facebook
or something.
There's also a really nice
caching story
because we are able to generate
the bundled image
such that its name is
an MB5 hash
of its very pixel content.
So you can set
"never expires" headers
on that resource.
The browser can cache it
locally.
And if the code ever changes--
Like, if you change
one of the images and redeploy,
then your script
would have a reference
to a different MB5-named
image.
So in other words,
you can cache permanently
on the client,
but you're never at risk that
that client code will refer
to the wrong image.
It's a little complicated,
but really, the point is
you don't have to think
about it,
you just get the benefit.
Okay, so with that
as background,
let's talk about
what ClientBundle is.
ClientBundle generalizes
this concept
to arbitrary resource types.
Let's walk through one.
So I'm gonna create an interface
called MyBundle
that extends ClientBundle.
I'll create an instance
using GWT.create,
which is the magic call
that allows this cogeneration
to happen.
And then I can do--
this is very much in line
with ImageBundle.
I can refer to smiley.gif.
And when I call this method
"smileyImage" in code,
it'll return me a resource
that represents a sprite
within the bundled image.
I can have another image,
and I can be sure that
this will get
bundled together nicely.
But for the first time
with ClientBundle,
you can do other things.
You can bundle in, for example,
text resources.
So let's say, rather than
configuring your application
in Javacode,
you'd like to keep the config
in a separate XML file
as part of your
project structure.
That doesn't mean you actually
want to serve an XML file
to the client in order
to make this go, right?
It would be wasteful.
So I can instead create a method
like this called appConfig.
And it will automatically
compile in the text
of that XML
into my JavaScript.
I can do the same thing
with--
for example,
if it's a larger
text resource,
I can specify
the external text resource type
as the return value.
And that has an API
that allows there
to be a level of indirection.
It's an asynchronous request.
So that,
depending on other settings,
it can either be bundled,
or it can be fetched.
In the case where
it's fetched--
if it's a large file that's
rarely used, for example--
its contents are MB5-encoded.
I mean, its name
is MB5-encoded.
So you can use the same
perfect caching trick
for large things.
I used wordlist as an example.
Because you can imagine
a spellchecker
with a large wordlist
that you wanted to download
might be something
you would want to cache.
You can even do crazy things,
like PDFs.
If there was some reason
you needed a PDF or,
I don't know,
WAV data or MP3 data,
you can actually do that
as well.
And this data resource type--
the return type here--
it has a method called
"get URL."
And that URL, depending
on the browser,
may be one of a couple
different things.
On a browser--
say an older browser--
it might be an actual URL
to your server.
But on a newer browser
that supports data URLs,
it actually might literally be
a data URL containing
the Base64-encoded bits
of that thing.
In other words,
I can bundle PDF data--
just as an example--
directly into my compiled
JavaScript.
So you have a lot of control
over how your resources
get deployed
and downloaded.
One of the coolest things,
which I'll come back to
in a second,
is CSS processing.
You can do, um--
you can bundle CSS files
directly
into your JavaScript code
instead of making separate
HTTP requests.
But you can also do a lot
of fancy things with the CSS
as you bundle it,
which I'll come back to.
But let's just go
really quickly
through the text resource
example.
So again, I'm gonna have
my app.config.xml file.
I want to make it available
to my application code
by calling this method
appConfig.
Just declare it like that.
Let's say that the XML file
itself looks like this.
It's got settings that I want
to compile into my app,
so animation speed may be
a failover strategy.
All right, this just needs
to be available
on your class path
at compile time.
So this is some code where
I'm actually gonna use
this bundle.
I'll grab the instance
in the bundle variable there.
I'll call the appConfig
method,
which returns
the text resource.
It has a getText method
that gives me the XML
that was attached
to my compiled script.
And then I can pass that into
the GWT XML library,
and set up my application.
So there's a few
really cool points here.
Obviously,
it's great to know
that this is going
to succeed.
It's not gonna require
a round trip.
It's compiled into
your script.
You can use the final format
you want--in this case, XML.
You might use JSON
for config these days.
And then
the most exciting part
is CSS resource.
We actually have
a CSS parser.
And because we're going through
all the trouble of parsing it,
we figured we might as well
throw in
some extra features
to help you deal with CSS
while you're at it.
Things like defining constants
in CSS
is something that
a lot of people have wanted
for a long time.
And we can give that
to you today
with ClientBundle.
I mean, maybe, maybe,
if you're extremely ambitious,
you'd use some sort of crazy,
you know,
SED script or PERL script
in your own CSS
to achieve the same effect.
But it's nice to know that
you're getting a real parser
that can actually crosscheck
if you refer to it a value.
For example, scary color
for an error message, right?
Scary color does actually,
in fact,
map onto something
that was defined, right?
If I misspelled it, that would
be a compile time error.
That's another
really nice benefit.
Because CSS is still
awesome right now,
and it's not--
it's more awesome
than reliable.
For now.
Obviously it's going to improve.
But for now.
There may be cases where
you need to do different things.
Right now, the rounded
border radius is an example
of where you might want
to do that.
So you can actually
use conditional constructs
to define CSS rules differently
in different cases.
I think this one's
pretty self-evident.
But the values there are--
differ by name properties.
And then, really,
there's way more to say
about what CssResource
can do.
It obviously can adminify--
so remove white space
and comments from your CSS,
which really adds up.
It can even obfuscate the names
of the CSS classes.
If you're careful about how--
the discipline you use
to refer to CSS names
within your Java source code,
the CSS generator can actually
obfuscate those names.
Your code never knows
the difference.
But what's actually downloaded
is smaller,
runs faster, and so on.
There's additional
fancy spriting with tiling.
And you can even,
from a CSS rule,
call back into your Java code
to get a value
that gets concatenated into
the CSS
that then gets injected.
So lots of fancy stuff.
If you research it--
just do a Google search
and you'll see lots
of examples.
There's a CSS resource
cookbook on Google Code.
Okay, so layouts.
Another big area.
First thing to know
about layout is don't do it.
In other words,
don't do it yourself.
If you find yourself
writing code
in response to the resize
event--
the window resize event--
you're already losing.
Because it's such
a worse user experience
when you have to run code
to adjust the way
things are laid out
than to have the browser
do it itself in native code.
So if you're doing anything
like measuring things,
like, how long is this div,
exactly?
You know, you're asking
for offset widths
and things like that.
You're almost guaranteed
to be on a path
to bad performance.
Instead, like I said,
you want to use implicit layout.
Have the browser do it.
So for probably borderline
excruciating details--
no, no, no, extremely
interesting details--
talk to Kelly Norton and--
I mean, talk to him,
but go to his talk
"Measuring Milliseconds,"
which is, I think,
the one right after this.
And you will really
find it interesting.
Okay, but the downside is
we use tables
and a lot of other things
that are lamented by us
and everybody else in order
to try to simulate
the right kind of
constraint-base layout.
Width 100% works really well
and consistently,
generally.
But inevitably people want--
occasionally want
application-style layout,
where it takes
the entire browser window.
And if you resize
the browser window,
everything resizes
along with it.
So you want to use Height 100%,
naturally.
It's the first thing
people do, right?
But that never works.
[laughter]
It just doesn't.
And it fails wonderfully
and differently
in different browsers.
And I day "fails"--
I mean, it fails if you consider
it looking completely awful
and not working well.
That's--that's--
It doesn't actually crash
your computer.
It doesn't format
your hard drive,
but it makes your app
completely useless.
So that's a pretty big fail.
But--oh, actually, yeah.
Let me show you what I mean.
So this isn't--this isn't
so much a failure.
This is more just
how things can not look great.
So in the mail sample
that we ship--
I mean, we're actually
doing this right now
because we didn't have
a better way of doing it
in the past.
You guys have,
I'm sure, seen this.
But, like, watch
as I drag this around.
See that laginess?
That's horrible.
And I'm not blaming Firefox
for this.
This is just sort of the way
it has to happen.
Because the window
on resize event
has to run some
JavaScript code and so on.
But back--you know,
this is Firefox 3.
At this time, the layout
engine's still somewhat slow.
So you can't literally
run that event
for every single time
that the browser is resized
by a single pixel, right?
So it has to have
this artificial delay.
And consequently
you get this yuckiness.
All right, not to mention
getting the code
to work well at all
is hard.
and you have to kind of
already be an Ajax expert,
which is kind of the reason
GWT was invented
is so that you don't have
to be right.
All right, now I'll show you
what it looks like--
Actually, first I'll tell you
a couple more things.
In Standards mode, we do have
some additional
reliable behavior with CSS.
And you can actually get
constraint-based layout
that does what you want.
And you don't have
to hook re--resize.
So we're gonna have
an updated set of panels in 2.0.
And I'll show you the new
and improved DockPanel.
This is the well-known
onModuleLoad.
So this probably isn't
the final name of this panel.
This is really still
basically prototype code.
But let's say
you instantiate it.
You specify a unit,
but that unit can be anything.
And then you specify sizes
for things
in various types
of constraints.
It looks pretty familiar
if you've used DockPanel before.
We did also add the ability
to add splitters
just directly into
the DockPanel.
So for sophisticated layouts,
it can work well.
And a couple of other things
I want to set.
So this is pretty
familiar-looking UI code.
This is the code you've always
been wanting to write.
But let's look at how
this actually looks.
So first of all, it's fast.
Because we're using
CSS for everything.
You can see that I can't
move the window fast enough
to outpace what's happening.
Here it keeps up with me.
Now, it's interesting
to note that
no JavaScript code is running
as I'm resizing here.
This is all based
on CSS constraints
and the way that
that panel happens to be--
to use them and construct them.
As I mentioned,
you got splitters here
that you can use.
You've got internal scrolling.
We also did a little example
of a stack panel
that uses the same sort
of technique.
And getting the stack panel
to resize properly
when nested in another thing--
I don't know,
if you've ever tried this,
it can be a real hassle.
It just works
with the new approach.
So you specify various
different kinds of constraints.
In fact,
it was recognized that
this is pretty much
the same set of constraints
that you get when designing
Cocoa apps on OS X.
And then we even
were able to--
as you specify
that you want to change
the size of something
from one size to another--
we can make that animate.
So for example,
if I double click on this,
I will get an automatic
resize,
which is nice.
So what I'm really showing
there
is an approach to layouts.
So that particular panel
isn't the thing
to be excited about
necessarily.
It's that we're gonna be able
to take that same approach
to recreate
all the other panels.
And they will tend
to just work
exactly like you
had hoped they would.
Okay, a few last things
that I just can't
not mention.
We've added some compiler flags.
There's one called
disableClassMetadata.
The -X means you better know
what you're doing
before you do this.
But there's certain constructs
in Java--
Callingobj.getClass
or clazz.getName--
forces us to compile
in class literals.
And those class literals
have names that are strings
that show up and, you know,
for a couple reasons,
that's not great.
But if you really don't
actually care
what clazz.getName returns--
You don't care that is says,
you know,
com.example.mywonderfulapp.
You just want it to return
a stable string.
Then we can do this.
Here's the Showcase metadata.
I snipped out just the part
where there are class literals,
with their names
and everything.
That's at one-point font.
And I flip this switch on,
and we've got
between 5% and 10%
script reduction.
And here's what it looks like
after.
It's not huge,
but on a big application,
this can really add up.
But again,
less code to download,
less code to parse.
It actually runs faster
because
you're not constructing
as much
when you're creating
class literals.
And it's a little bit more
of an obscurity benefit.
When people are looking
at your source,
they don't see all
the type names and so on.
In a similar vein
we've got disableCastChecking.
Because nobody--I hope nobody--
writes code like this.
So somebody wrote
this silly method that
you pass in an animal,
and then just you try
to make it quack,
but you don't know what kind
of animal it is.
So you just--you cast it
to a quacker.
And then you call quack on it.
But you know,
you're being defensive,
so you catch
the ClassCastException, right?
Because, I mean,
people could pass in
non-quackable objects,
obviously.
But people are laughing
because
nobody writes this code,
right?
But yet, we still, you know,
technically,
have to generate code
that checks this anyway
at run time.
And that's unfortunate
because
it means there's lots
of tables
that we have to produce
to say
this can be cast to that,
and so on.
And we have to emit
the code
to do the dynamic
cast checking,
which actually
slows things down a lot.
You turn this flag on,
and this is what you get
in the compiled output.
So in other words,
it trusts you.
It basically says,
"I'm never gonna throw
ClassCastException.
You better not depend
on that being thrown."
But assuming you didn't write
stupid code,
in my humble opinion,
then you're gonna see
real speed-ups.
So, um, a 1% size reduction
and 10% speed improvement
in performance-sensitive code.
Which, 10% for merely
flipping on a flag is not bad.
That was actually an average.
We worked with them
to try out this flag,
and indeed, 10% faster
with a simple rebuild.
Okay, a couple more tidbits,
and then we'll do some Q & A.
So GWT RPC is polymorphic.
And so one of the things
that you find
if you use a lot of RPC
is that
the RPC cogenerator tries
to infer what types
might be serializable.
So it kind of walks
the type hierarchy.
And if you send an animal,
it will try to find, you know,
all the different kind
of animals that there are.
Whether or not you actually
do want to send a rhinoceros
from the server
to the client...
It kind of--
If you have an RPC method
that returns type animal,
it has to be prepared
to receive a rhinoceros
over the wire.
So there are cases
where you can look at
your code output and say,
"I definitely will not
be sending rhinoceroses
from the server
to the client."
Rhinoceri? Anyway...
And so you can just tell
the RPC code generator,
"Here's a list of types
that I am definitely
not wanting you
to serialize."
And it turns out that
this is really beneficial.
So you can just go through
and easily just chop out
a whole bunch of code,
and make your script smaller.
So it's really pragmatic
and easy to use.
Another one that comes up a lot
with RPC is the fact
that people sometimes want
to have
the functionality
of RequestBuilder,
but with the simplicity
of RPC.
And so we've introduced a way
to actually combine the two.
So you can take
an RPC interface
and specify the RPC
RequestBuilder instance
that you'd like to use.
So that allows you
to do things like
set custom request headers
in HTTP.
Set time-outs--
all sorts of things.
You do that
to the RPC interface itself,
and every individual
RPC method call
within that interface
will use exactly that same
RequestBuilder process.
If you've used RPC
for anything non-trivial,
that will make sense.
And if you haven't,
it probably didn't make sense.
But that's okay.
There's even client-side
stack traces
on some browsers now.
So at least on Firefox,
this is reliable.
And we do it without
actually generating
any additional code.
There's a way to do it,
obviously,
by generating code
into the compiled script.
The compiler could do
all the bookkeeping and so on.
But we think that might be
a little too costly
in terms of size and speed.
But actually,
the browser is able to
give you stack backtrace
on exceptions in JavaScript.
It's tricky because
the names are obfuscated
in production.
So the stack traces look like
a bunch of obfuscated names.
But the compiler now also
produces symbol maps
that you can have
on the server.
So that if you catch
an exception on the client,
generate a stack trace,
send that up in obfuscated form
to your server,
Then you can combine that
with the symbol maps,
and then you can see
the full--
the actual names
of the methods
that were involved in
the stack trace on the client.
So it's pretty cool
when you actually see it.
And that is increasingly
working.
Last thing that came up is...
people--
We introduced last year at I/O
something called
JavaScript Overlay Types,
which let's you model
JavaScript objects
directly into
the Java type system.
So I can create a Java class
that I superimpose
directly on a JavaScript
object.
And it can be faster.
Especially for JSON,
it's a really efficient way
to interact with JSON objects.
The problem is people wanted
to use it for JSON.
So they want to send
JSON structures
from the server to
the client.
But the server can't
actually use the JSNI--
the JavaScript code
on the server.
And overlay types
didn't support interfaces.
So in other words,
for the server to use
that same class is impossible.
So now we've introduced
the ability for overlay types
to implement interfaces
so that on the server side
you can implement
some JSON-oriented interface--
let's say person--
that's basically
a being-like interface.
You know, get first name,
get last name.
You can implement it
on the server
using regular Java bytecode.
You can implement it
on the client
using an overlay type.
And so you can actually share
a whole bunch of code,
in terms of that interface,
between the client
and the server.
Again, if you've
never done this,
that probably doesn't make
a whole lot of sense.
But if you have, hopefully
you will see the benefit.
And we can talk a lot more
about that.
We have office hours
we're gonna have scheduled
to talk about the compiler
and lots of other good stuff.
And hopefully, we'll just
bump into each other
in the hallways.
And that is pretty much it.
Um, I think let's go ahead
and, uh--
We have about five minutes
left.
We can do some quick Q & A,
but please, do come
to the microphones
since the audio needs to go
into YouTube.
[applause]
Thank you.
Yes?
man: The, uh--
Sorry, it's loud.
The code splitting stuff
looks really cool.
I'm wondering what it does
for localized resources.
Um, CSS...
If there's anything...
Johnson: Oh, yeah.
That's a great question.
That was a huge point
I failed to make.
When you combine ClientBundle
and code splitting,
it's really awesome
because ClientBundle, you know,
literally can, like, bundle in
the variables and so on.
In other words, you have fields
that get generated
by the ClientBundle that
contain things like CSS values--
literals, and even
the PDF example, right?
That would become a field
at compile time.
And then code splitting
can actually do
the static analysis to say
this huge chunk of CSS
isn't actually reachable
from the startup fragment.
And so it actually can push
resources automatically
out into the different
fragments.
So they're loaded only along
with the code that needs them.
Thank you for that question.
Glad I messed that one up.
Uh, yes? Whomever.
man: Okay, so the--
[clears throat]
Obviously, as soon as we can
start debugging in any browser,
we're gonna upgrade right away.
That's pretty awesome.
But I noticed that
console window
that has an instance
for each browser.
I mean, can we still run
in hosted mode
with our own server?
Johnson: Yes.
man: Okay.
Johnson: Yes, definitely.
man: Cool. Awesome.
Good improvement.
Johnson: Yes, you can.
man: So the question is,
do you have any plans
to have a different way
of organizing the layout
instead of writing code?
I had a quick look
at Android,
and they have this XML
declaration
of the positioning
of the widgets.
Do you have some plan
of putting some work into it
so that we don't have to build
the panels in Java and...
Johnson: Yes. It's a little bit
further out in the pipeline,
but you might have seen
a design doc on our wiki
for something called
Declarative UI.
It's now called UI Binder.
But it is--it's an XML-based
declarative way
of specifying all the same stuff
that you would do in code.
man: And you have no timeline
on when this would be able
to play around?
Johnson: I mean,
I can't be trusted
because I'm always the guy
saying, "Yeah,
let's add it to 2.0!"
But then, you know,
the product managers and so on,
they don't like that.
So I have to underpromise.
Maybe--
hopefully overdeliver.
But I can't really say that
it'll be ready for 2.0.
But not too much longer.
It's in use at Google.
In fact, you'll see--
If you go to a lot of GWT talks,
you'll see examples of apps
that use that heavily already
within Google, so...
Yes?
man: Hi. The code splitting
stuff looks great.
We've been really hurting
for the lack of it.
The question I have is,
you say that you build
a dependence graph.
And so the thing that naturally
pops into my mind is
how do I either avoid
or break those dependences?
What kind of things
do I have to worry about?
Johnson: Okay, so that is
exactly what the story
of your compile is all about?
man: Mm-hmm.
Johnson: So the story
of your compile,
Reading Tea Leaves for
an Optimized Future talk,
goes into that.
It takes you step by step
through that scenario
and how to solve it.
man: Great. Thanks.
Johnson: Yeah.
man: Hi.
Johnson: Hi.
man: Does the CSS compiler
warn you
if you write CSS
that doesn't actually get used,
or the other way around?
Reference CSS that you forgot
to put in?
Johnson: Yes, that's another
thing I forgot to mention.
If you organize your CSS
right,
it's like dead CSS
elimination.
man: Nice.
Johnson: Right.
man: Hi, um, what's the timeline
for the 2.0 general release?
Johnson: That's another one
of those things
where I have made
bold proclamations in the past
and gotten burned
because I was too optimistic.
I really--I can't say,
but it will be--
we would like to start
thinking about
trying to get it out Q3.
[laughter]
man: Okay, thanks.
Johnson: So it's not, like,
a year out.
So to be clear,
all this stuff is actually
in the trunk right now.
You could--
if you're sufficiently brave,
you can check this out as
a version and run it yourself.
In fact, Google projects
using GWT
do run off the tip of trunk.
So again, the apps that
you'll see today and tomorrow,
I think you'll find
very compelling applications.
These are all built
with the Bleeding Edge.
Yes?
man: When you were talking
about code splitting,
you mentioned the example
of, say, a settings page.
And it struck me that
one of the first things
that a settings page
might want to do
once the code is down
is go to the server
and get all my settings.
Is there any way
to package data
with the code
and the code split
to avoid that extra
round trip?
Johnson:
That's a good question.
It's probably one--
We'll have a little more time
to talk about that
if you come to the
Reading the Tea Leaves talk.
Or maybe in the hallway.
But not out of the question.
You have to think about
cachability.
If you mix code that doesn't
change over time
with data that does--
man: Yeah, but I mean the
first time you get that code...
Johnson: Yeah, yeah,
potentially.
So there might be some tricks
like that we can pull.
But let's talk more.
man: Thanks.
Johnson: We are out of time now,
guys, I'm sorry.
If there are still
remaining questions,
we'll catch you guys
out in the hallway.
Thanks.
[applause]
And stick around
for Kelly's talk.